these movies where it's coming of age
these you know real grounded stories
with characters and it seems like
there's none of that and it's all either
superhero uh I mean no I'm not saying
it's bad I'm just saying well for me I
just miss that I miss that sort of it
was nice to grow up with that and see
you know kids my age and like oh my gosh
look what he's going through Coming of
Age like rights of Passage was they were
always a River's Edge remember like what
a great movie like these movies we as
teenagers were watching these other
teenagers grapple with really hard
things I mean you even had like even
blue velvet like they were young people
and they were thrust into like crazy
situations and so that time was such a
good time to be in Hollywood as a young
person because there was so many great
projects always um around